you grew up in denmark
i know you went to university there and
that is interesting
there's a term getting to denmark which
means getting to a high functioning
society amongst the elites in the globe
like when they go to
davos and other places i haven't been to
office but other conversations with
these globalist type people are like we
have to get to denmark
which is a really great compliment it
means what the people want is what they
get
in their government when we look at
america and
how amazing we've performed on a
capitalistic basis but how poorly we've
performed
in government services healthcare and
education or a disaster here
we spend the most we get the least but
on a capitalist basis we have the giant
companies
that for a little 300 million person
country are
you know taking over the globe uh and we
are the benefactors of that as a country
what do you think about that balance
where our government's completely
dysfunctional we don't get what we need
out of it yet we spend all this money
but capitalism
you know unconstrained capitalism in
america i would call it or very vibrant
uh you know less rules based capitalism
let's call it
fluid capitalism extreme capitalism
there's got to be a word for it uh
extreme capital stage
late stage i think is the insulting word
for it because it kind of says like this
is the end
of the game yes so late stage capitalism
or
extreme capitalism i'll call it um
what would it was it worth it or not
worth it
because we do you know have google and
facebook and amazon and all these
incredible services uber
airbnb we we are the owners of those as
a country those companies right so is it
worth it or not
well first of all we're not the owners
there's a small handful of people who
are
the owners who get the benefits uh the
lion's share of the benefits of those
companies so
positing as though like hey this is a
shared benefit to america
is is doing a disservice to all the
people who this is not a benefit at all
in fact they are the prey
uh if you look at companies like
facebook and google there's certainly
people who benefit from it and then
there's certain people who are being
exploited by it and i think
perhaps that's even more concrete when
you look at the gig economy and you look
at
companies like uber or doordash
or any of these other atrocious
companies who
essentially have built their wealth of
exploitation and violation
of of people and misclassification
misclassifying them
as as contractors instead of workers but
let's put that aside and take the
big picture first which is sort of is
capitalism a good thing i
this is one of those arguments that i
always find so fascinating because
in the context of you saying getting to
denmark that's the goal right
denmark is a capitalist system what are
you talking about they're free markets
they're
free companies they're not state-owned
companies
um much of western europe has simply
decided that there's certain parts of
the economy that certain parts of
society that operate
poorly under market economics they are
education and healthcare in particular
so if you look at uh
most of western europe and it's not just
denmark although denmark is perhaps a
well really all of scandinavia is a
particularly well functioning
uh example of the government running
health care
not paying for insurance running like
the doctors at the hospitals they're
employed by the government the same
thing
in the uk and you take education the
universities in denmark they're not
sort of private universities where the
government kicks in
on the debt scale no they're run by the
government and you know what they're run
really well
in fact when i came from denmark to here
i was astounded at just how poorly those
two parts worked
when i came to the u.s i had a
girlfriend at the time who was enrolled
in loyola university
and first of all the cost was just
obscene i think we were paying something
like
30 or 35 grand a year for uh for that i
i forget the specifics
when you come from a country like
denmark where education is not only
paid for by the government there's a
stipend for any student to
cover basic living expenses explain that
because that's mind-blowing to americans
explain how the stipend works how much
is it how do you get it technically
like it it's not means tested so if you
are a well actually that's not entirely
true if if you work um
uh anyway let me just go to the
basically the basics is that you get
about a thousand bucks a month
to pay for your living expenses while
you attend university and you can do
this for up to i think like
six years or something which a master's
degree in denmark is usually around five
years and then they allow you one year
to essentially gap it most people don't
necessarily finish their master's degree
in five years
and then i think there's probably also
an extension available if you pursue a
phd
the the interesting part for me though
where you can sort of say
um like how is this affordable
is that in an american frame of mind you
think like oh is the government really
paying like 30 or 40 or 50 grand a year
for all these students of course they're
not
the education system is incentivized to
be efficient
my entire education at the copenhagen
business school
i looked at this once and i thought it
was something like 18 000
for three-year bachelor's degree like
that that was what it cost the danish
state to produce that education and you
go like
well that's obviously a lot less i know
there are some examples for in-state
tuition and so on and so forth but
if you just say what does it cost to
educate anyone who
wants a higher education and give them
the stipend
to allow them to live while they do so
what will it cost society
and the answer is a whole lot less than
you would think a whole lot less than
what is spent on the american system
which is a system that's heavily gate
kept right yeah either you have to have
these extreme
grades and you almost have to prepare
for college in kindergarten
or you have to be very wealthy and
that's a broken system and then
on healthcare it's the same thing
denmark has great healthcare now
every society even if they have great
healthcare have people who complain
about that healthcare that's just
the nature of it right but if you look
at the overall stats life expectancy
and and and all these basic things
denmark does
just way better than the us and denmark
spent something i think it's like eight
percent of gdp
and the u.s spent 18 percent of gdp yeah
on health care so obviously
here you have two of the most important
functions of society healthcare and
education
the american system is a for-profit
capitalist system
that is just being whipped by
state funded and run systems and you go
like you know what
that should just give you some room for
pause here that maybe the capitalist
system
in all factors of the society is not the
clear answer
that doesn't mean that we can't have
for-profit companies producing phones
yeah that works great like
hey get your phone on the free market
you just you're not that interested in
the free market when you're
about to die yeah i mean it it does seem
like when you do this hybrid of because
we do have
medicare and we have some
state-sponsored things and we have
some like and people love them well they
do love it
yeah it's like they're fighting for it
that's how they make their decision on
how to vote is for that
so it is even more we just have to go
one way or the other you know i think it
has to be completely capitalistic or it
has to be
you know in a free market where
customers are paying but we've picked
the worst of all worlds to
tie it to employment
creates the most um unhealthy dynamic
but
i mean i have people who will can't work
for some of the startups i've invested
in because the healthcare is not good
enough
or they can't leave a company that's hit
scale because they can't get as good
healthcare
so now you have employers dealing with
employees who either
can't don't want to go or don't want to
leave
and it just creates this total
dysfunction right like in terms of like
we were talking about before and
isn't that ironic that here you have a
market sort of approach that's
essentially undermining the free market
it's
undermining the the free movement of
labor
people can't change jobs they can't do
all these things and what are we doing
this for for some
sort of uh ideological obsession that
the free market is the right answer for
everything
it is so clearly not the right answer
for health care and i think
failing to address that is creating some
of those
great frictions in american society and
american politics and i think
hopefully we're finally getting to the
point where people have just had enough
and of course they've had enough you
look at all the objective measures of
medical bankruptcies or the outcome of
the medical system you go like
this [ __ ] is broken and i say that as
someone who's very rich in in sort of
comparison to
the average standard and i can afford
any kind of healthcare i
want and i've gotten any kind of
healthcare i wanted and the system is
still
completely insane i go in to get some
sort of checkup i have to fill out more
papers than i don't know applying for a
driver's license in the soviet union
would have required right
you go like the system is more baroquely
uh bureaucratic and just the whole
wrestling of everything with insurances
and so on
and it's just bust like on all objective
factors the system is just bust and it
needs to be
replaced